hello everybody and welcome to day
number two of my RAID rewards flipping
progress video as you might call it we
are starting off today at about 59 mil
we've gotten about 5 or 6 mil in profit
so far uh the main items we've done are
the dragon thone axe Dragon Sword Dragon
Harpoon and we did actually get a
twisted buckler flip for about 2.3 mil
last night now today we're going to try
the Dragon Hunter crossbow and maybe
these two items the ancestral hat and
the Den's ball work if it does get down
cheap enough and uh again we're using
all uh G tracker for all our pricings
and um so if you want to check them out
there will be a link in the description
for that so hopefully uh we don't end up
losing too much money today and uh yeah
let's get
started all right guys we're on to day
two of flipping the new raid rewards
we're starting at about 58.6 mil now
let's just get right into it so we're
going to start off with the Twisted
buckler for sure again we want to try
another one of those cuz we got almost 3
mil in profit from the last one
Twisted
buckler ACC trade price is
42 and the last update was as of nine
since item has not updated in a while uh
I'm going to try buying it at 40
999999 or maybe even cheaper maybe I
should go just for 40 mil yeah I gotta
make
breakfast not that that really is going
to relate to this too much
uh but we'll try buying it for 40 mil
yeah go for the Dragon Sword it is worth
looking at the actively traded pra uh
which seems to be extremely high which
is crazy
[Music]
um does that seem
reasonable 12 mil uh that's where it was
when we went to bed and here it is kind
of level out raising
up I think that's reasonable we were
gone actually 4 minutes we're [__]
making toast Dragon Sword already sold
for 12600 um you can see it's around
level 900 but it seems to be like up
down up down so I think this might be a
good time to
actually uh try to get 1 mil flip off
the sword because we have been
consistently getting 6 or 700k uh but no
more than that uh so happy another 600k
easily down in the pocket Twisted
buckler is yet to buy uh but I'm looking
forward to that as well all right we'll
be back in a minute okay guys so we did
buy the Dragon Hunter crossbow for 44.2
mil
I think I might have overpaid for this a
little bit
cuz oh look here it's
44.1 and but we'll try to sell it for 46
I guess I mean there's nothing else we
can really do at this point uh kind
looks like it's going up maybe looks
great to me all right we just have to
hope that this sells that would still be
a 2 mil profit which I'd be super happy
with we're back with another Dragon
Sword flip which is nice I'm happy about
that that's another 700k in profit the
Dragon under crossbow is still not sold
and it's really testing my resolve not
to drop it down
but no no we'll leave it like that put
another offer for the Dragon Sword
because we're getting consistent 600
700k flips on this uh we'll leave this
for another half an hour or so and then
we might drop it a bit so we did end up
reducing the Dragon Hunter crossbow to
45200 so I really hope it sells on top
of that uh we have flipped another
Dragon Sword for another 700k profa like
we is getting these done pretty pretty
quickly like one two
three that's uh 2.1 mil in under an hour
probably so we'll just man we'll
continue buying these it seems like we
have the margin pretty much locked down
we could try selling them for a little
bit more uh but at the same time I'd
rather just sell them right away and I
really hope this sells otherwise we're
going to try to dump it for what we
bought it for um yeah still going pretty
well so we ended up uh ditching the
Dragon Hunter crossbow we lost what 700k
on it but not too bad and I was
expecting it to flip quicker and it
wasn't so um yeah that being said we're
going to probably switch back to the uh
Twisted buckler all right I think we're
going to try buying it for 41.5 mil the
other option is the ancestral hat and
definitely trades less and could have a
bigger margin on it but it does look
like it's consistently kind of dropping
here where the Twisted buckler has kind
of evened out more so we're going to try
buying it for we could go for 415 or
maybe
42.2
probably going to be closer to the
actual market price for now we're going
to put in for 41.5 and then once it
updates maybe move it up so
Twisted
buckler
K 501k sure all right so this is great
I'm just hanging out on the couch having
a chill day and just slowly watching
flips come in so we actually changed up
the Harpoon or the uh the Dragon Sword
for Dragon Harpoon I think we flipped
that for a 600k profit it yeah about
600k uh we bought the Twisted buckler
for 47.7 mil uh now we're going to try
to sell it for
43.9 uh it's been probably 45 minutes so
I'm not really sure how long we're going
to wait on that one uh next I think
we're just going to do the Harpoon again
cuz it actually bought and sold quite
quickly uh just do it again for
12341 and yeah come back with another
update so bad news we ended up losing
quite a bit on the Twisted buckler uh I
can see down here we bought it for 42.7
mil and we had to dump it for 40.5 so
that is about a 2 mil loss uh on the
plus side we did actually flip a dragon
Harpoon for a 4K profit and these pretty
much nothing so uh let's see where we
stand anyway we started at about 58 mil
and uh we haven't really gone we
actually gained some money surprisingly
um but nothing substantial yet so we're
going to go ahead and try um the
Dragon Hunter crossbow again we're going
to underdo it a bit um maybe do 42.6
mil it's a little higher up there maybe
uh 43.5
mil
Dragon Hunter
crossbow 43 point or 435
50k and I will try to get one of those
and on top of that I'm not sure if we
should go for the dragon Harpoon cuz
look uh it is totally kind of slowly
crashing doesn't even look to be having
a big margin the Dragon Sword is
actually Rising but same deal doesn't
seem to have a very good margin and um
it could crash down
again but we do have some money we want
to spend so I think we're going to go
for the Harpoon Maybe and Just low ball
the
harpoon
and maybe do if it continues to go down
maybe
do 10 11 mil
maybe all right and yeah so not the best
flips but hopefully uh these will work a
little
better so I kind of [__] this up a
little bit uh not as bad as you'd think
though so I went to go readjust my price
uh to $
43999 and we instantly sold it
accidentally for
$42.99 but we actually sold it for just
40K under what I was attempting to put
it in for so actually we came out of
that with a 400k profit not awful now
I'm going to head to work and I'm not
going to leave any offers in while I'm
gone H just cuz it it's not really a
good idea so we're going to pull this up
for now and just do another price check
and we're at 59 mil so so we've
successfully gained 6 mil pretty much
since we've started and yeah we'll come
back once we're uh done doing the work
all right we're back from work and uh
some of the items have crashed even more
uh mainly this Dragon Sword is down to 7
mil so I'm kind of torn I feel like it
might do a kind of similar thing in the
morning I'm not sure if I should leave
some items in overnight cuz look it went
down they kind of went back up I could
see it going back up from 7 mil because
this is pretty alltime low uh same time
last night is about when it hit this low
Point well 4:00 a.m. it's not quite
there yet um but yeah we might consider
doing that for now we're probably just
going to do the Dragon Hunter
crossbow and uh the Dragon Sword another
thing worth noting is we almost um have
enough for the Den's B work which might
be worth flipping uh but for now we'll
do the Dragon Hunter crossbow we're
going to undercut uh or not undercut but
definitely low ball the offer pretty
hard maybe
at um 40 into 40 do
400 Dragon
Hunter 39
49k and now the Dragon Sword has gotten
so cheap we might actually be able to do
three items at a time now uh cuz the
dragon sword's down to about 7 mil we
could maybe try put it in
for uh six mil try to buy it for
maybe m is that a little bit to yeah we
do six mil we can always readjust this
after do
71 and that leaves us with 12 mil now
how much is the dragon
Harpoon didn't actually check that
Dragon Harpoon is down to 13 mil we
might be able to blow ball with what we
have
left and uh we
have 12.5 mil that might just be enough
um looks like it sold for 14 at 10:00
all right we'll build it in for 12260
and we'll come back when we made some
progress so we have successfully bought
one of everything uh the dragon Harpoon
and sword are already in to sell we just
bought a twisted buckler for 35.6 mil uh
now here's the current price as of about
10 minutes ago uh we could try to sell
for 36.1 but it also did sell in the
last hour for
38.8 and with there being a lot less
coming into the game right now I think
we're going to go for a bit of a higher
amount maybe try for
38.6 and uh yeah we might as well uh go
big or go home I guess
38 five
6 five no that's too much
559 38
559 and uh we bought it
for we just got to double check
everything okay it looks good and uh
that would leave us with a 3 mil profit
so hopefully this will sell uh we're
going to go play our account cuz I feel
like that will make us a little bit less
impatient than just staring at the
screen for an hour uh so yeah we'll be
back with some progress so we're back
and we did actually sell the Dragon
Sword and the dragon Harpoon I'll claim
the money for both of those I think we
got 400k on the dragon
Harpoon
um actually
525k so not too bad uh dragon sword got
a bit less only
about 300K uh still not awful so we're
going to go ahead and do the dragon
Harpoon again uh we just sold it for
that so we'll probably go ahead and uh
probably buy for the same amount but
let's just recheck what is looking like
Anyway doesn't seem to have changed too
much so we're going to go ahead and buy
it for the same price uh now now for the
Dragon Sword we might change the price
here um because we did have it in
for 8 mil now it be nice to get a little
bit more on that 300K I wouldn't say is
worth it
for the volatility if that's a word of
the items they're going up and down a
lot I mean they have stabilized a bit
here but I wouldn't say that's entirely
worth it um so we're just going to
slowly Edge it down and hopefully we can
get more sales let's try
788 um 7
899k which is an extra 100K always helps
and we'll try to buy it for that price
and we'll come back H hopefully when
this twist buckler has
sold ah so we lost quite a bit of money
on this Twisted buckler again it just
wouldn't sell and it's been it was like
3 hours and we kept reducing it down so
we sold it about a 1.5 mil loss which
sucks but it can't be helped yeah look
at that oh wa it was more than that
wasn't it
about 1.6 mil not great and uh dragon
sword we ended up just selling at a
break even standpoint as well so overall
uh we didn't really make much money
today we we tried and but we probably
just broke even to be
fair which I'm a little upset about but
I think what we're going to do to maybe
uh make this a little interesting is we
are going to put some offers in
overnight and I will update you in uh
the next update video so 59 mil what
should we do overnight now this is a
tricky question uh the I would have
loved to do the dens ball work but uh we
didn't quite get around to doing it look
at that jump like it was going till 10
p.m. strong and then bam just up 10 mil
13 mil I don't know what caused that
kind of just goes to show that it's
extremely difficult to predict a market
Okay so so what we're going to do is
we're going to put some offers in uh
extremely low just in case we do somehow
manag to snag an offer you never know
someone could do a raid there could be
not another offer and for something like
the ancestral hat that actually is not
going to trade very much during the
night who knows so we'll go ahead and uh
try the ancestral hat ancestral hat was
that it yeah and uh 35 mil is what it's
at roughly right now so we're going to
try it for
500k and 25
mil now if that completes we have a good
chance of actually making a good amount
of money back on top of that we're going
to what else could we put an offer in
for we could do the twist I really don't
want to do the Twisted buckler again
what about the Dragon Hunter crossbow ah
that probably is not going to be as
likely to have no one else selling it
this is not going to be cheap enough uh
we could lowball some Dragon Throne axes
cuz uh we did actually make a little bit
off those while we were waiting I don't
know if you noticed uh we flipped 23 of
them probably only got 75 70k profit so
not huge uh the dragon
sword um we could do the Dragon Sword
although it definitely is going to
continue to
drop let's just yeah I'll put offer in
for some of these at least dragon sword
you never
know uh try
5100k we'll do two how about all right I
really don't want to do the Twisted
buckler again but it's kind of the only
thing in the price range and this is you
know what let's just do it for this
medium price here assuming we actually
have enough that's a serious
undercut and that will be it guys I hope
you enjoyed the video anyway even though
I pretty much just suffered a bunch of
losses and I will see you guys in the
next update
video
a